ils étaient nombreux à attendre
patiemment devant les points de service
de la SAQ notamment à Montréal dans les
Laurentides et agatino fait c'est la
troisième fois que je viens que je viens
ici les deux les deux fois avant les
bureaux c'est un système fonctionnait
pas mais qu'on nous dit de revenir fait
que c'est la troisième fois que c'est la
tente est longue et puis la ligne elle
est aussi longue ça fait une heure et
puis la SEC n'est pas joignable par le
téléphone alors ça complique les choses
c'est compliqué surtout qu'on a d'autres
choses à faire j'ai de la chance
heureusement j'ai ma journée libre donc
je vais attendre toute la journée mais
malheureusement c'est quand même dommage
pour tous ceux qui travaillent c'est une
période difficile
le PDG de la Société de l'assurance
automobile admet que l'implantation le
mois dernier du nouveau système
informatique a connu des difficultés
parce que là on est en récupération de
tous les transactions qui se sont faits
durant le mois de février et qui vous
savez nos bureaux étaient roulaient
partiellement
pour donner des services diminuer durant
cette période-là alors là on est
vraiment récupération et c'est ça qui
crée aussi un peu d'achalandage mais la
SAQ s'engage maintenant à simplifier
l'inscription au niveau site ça clique
il y aura plus besoin de 4 documents
pour s'inscrire la carte d'assurance
maladie suffira des équipes spéciales
sont maintenant dépêchées dans les files
d'attente pour répondre à la clientèle
et les heures d'ouverture des points de
service sont allongés il y aura même des
succursales ouvertes les fin de semaine
mais tout ça ça prendra du temps ça ça
va durer
on pense qu'on va revenir à la normale
fin avril comme pour les passeports le
printemps dernier il faudra prendre son
mal en patience du stress moi
Jacques Bissonnière Radio-Canada
Montréal